euromax highlights and here's your host
kaine hamstet hi there and welcome to
our highlights of the past week which
this time around included these and
other stories
on the runway a young romanian designer
debuts at berlin fashion week
night moves in hamburg complete
strangers can swap apartments
medieval break ancient villages in italy
are being restored and turned into
vacation resorts
well his exploits defy reason and
seemingly the limits of human capacity
guillaume neri of france is one of the
world's best free divers and a former
world record holder who hit depths of an
amazing 117 meters without an oxygen
tank well in his later career he's now
focused more on underwater filmmaking
and so we caught up with him and his
partner to talk about their latest
efforts
images that show the beauty of an
extreme sport
one that's always overshadowed by the
specter of death
barely a season goes by without a free
diver dying
but for the creators of the film narcos
free diving is simply the most amazing
sport there is
we're trying trying to have a another
point of view
to
to what relating is we are not showing
um
we're not showing records or deep diving
we're trying to emphasize on on the
beauty of the sport
here in nice on france's mediterranean
coast free divers julie gautier and
guillaume neri prepare for today's shoot
with stretching and breathing exercises
at 100 meters below the water's surface
lungs shrink to the size of two oranges
do a lot of breathing exercise a lot of
stretching exercise in order to accept
this pressure the the key of deep diving
is to relax and accept
if you fight against the pressure you're
gonna feel the pain and it's gonna be
uncomfortable and you can hurt yourself
the two free divers have been a couple
for several years having met through
their sport
they branched out into filmmaking four
years ago with their first video free
fall
inspired by base jumping videos it shows
guillaume neri's free fall in dean's
blue hole in the bahamas
guillaume was in the bahamas for the
competition
and
we had this
camera and so yeah we have a good camera
we should make a movie he said okay just
take the camera and we made we made free
fall that we have now 18 million views
it's just crazy
their internet fans finance the couple's
next project
narcos was made more or less on their
own doorstep here in the bay of the
french sumer and in the mountains near
the cote d'azur
the short film deals with the hulu's
nations that free divers can have on
very deep dives
the classic rapture of the deep caused
by nitrogen narcosis
once guillaume had a vision of marrying
his girlfriend
visions and the narcosis and the rapture
of the depths are not always funny
sometimes
it's kind of
scary and
when i'm
a bit anxious before the dive it can be
a nightmare down there
today they're doing test shots for new
videos
julie gautier has always been fascinated
by the rapture of the deep though she's
never experienced it herself
it's especially strong during dives of
90 meters or more
during their shoots great depths don't
play a role here it's about their
collaboration underwater
and how the lack of heavy diving
equipment makes it special
you have a freedom of movement
underwater julie when she's filming me
she she can follow me
up and down she can
go at the same speed she can
turn around me
and free diving the sports relating is
freedom so filming on freediving is
filming with freedom
after the test shots the couple head
back to their apartment on the outskirts
of nice where their two-year-old
daughter melu awaits them
this season guillaume is taking a break
from competitions and world record
attempts
one reason for that is the death last
year of an american free diver
the couple want to use the time for more
film projects
so if we expect too much
we're going to be disappointed so no
expectation even if
deep inside of our mind we are like ah
we hope
he's gonna be successful again
narcos has been screened at various
festivals and can now be viewed online
too
the couple are also uploading a video
they shot in the underwater world of
french polynesia
well twice a year berlin fashion week
sees a raft of designers both new and
established flocked to the german
capital and last year junior designer
joanna ciulacu from romania won the
coveted designer for tomorrow prize and
as part of that award she also got to
have her own show at fashion week and so
we went to see her brand new collection
and how that award has given her career
a welcome boost
romanian designer joanna chalaku and a
fitting for her debut fashion show in
berlin
chalaku calls her collection hunters and
its 25 designs reflect the interaction
between hunter and prey
the cornerstone of this collection was
laid a year ago when chalaku won the
designer for tomorrow prize at berlin
fashion week
actually is one year and five days
yes
yeah i remember of course it was my
first big fitting and it was hectic
because we kept
switching models and i mean it's the
same now but it's more relaxed because i
already have the experience so i'm more
relaxed
one year ago chalaku was one of five
finalists for the designer for tomorrow
award chosen from a pool of 350
applicants
british fashion designer stella
mccartney was the competition's patron
and in the end mccartney and the panel
of fashion experts chose cheloku and her
paradox collection as the winner
she just really sort of
had a great point of view and a lovely
silhouette quite architectural quite
statement but at the same time quite
wearable and i think that's kind of what
i'm
looking for in these kind of things
somebody that's really new in the way
that they approach
design but also at the same time
somebody that you
you feel you want to wear
the award provided shilaku with
financial support and assistance in
establishing her own label
she's now opened her own studio in the
romanian capital bucharest
chalaku accompanied mccartney and her
team when they put on a show at paris
fashion week
and she visited the british designer at
her studio in london
it wasn't any more advices regarding
design which she knows best because i
think that
she thinks that i'm prepared already
so yeah it was more of a industry input
you know how business works
you know that's why i visited her studio
because i opened my studio so you know i
wanted to know what's the
you know the level of how many people
are they you know how they work how do
they manage everything so that was more
important
designer for tomorrow winners also get
the chance to stage their own show at
berlin fashion week
the models the pr the help backstage
they've all been organized for joanna
celaku
the young designer hopes to take the
fashion world by storm from her
headquarters in bucharest
she plans to produce her collection in
romania as well
it's her way of supporting her country's
economy and ensuring good quality
european clothing store chain peak and
kloppenburg dusseldorf has been
sponsoring the designer for tomorrow
competition since 2009.
the patron of this year's competition is
the american designer tommy hilfiger
chalaku's show kicks off the finale
and there's still time for her to enjoy
the attention and support that's on
offer before she has to stand on her own
two feet
there has been a lot of emotions for me
i never had so many emotions in my life
because of the you know winning and the
preparations before and now
you know again with the show again the
same feelings but i was grown up really
good so now i have the power to be on my
own i guess
after the show yuanachilaku is ready to
launch your career as an independent
designer
she's no longer a designer for tomorrow
she's creating fashions for today
well it's a pretty odd concept to think
of giving your house keys over to a
complete stranger and then letting them
spend the night in your private quarters
but that is indeed the idea behind the
hotel hamburg happening in the month of
july as an art project it's designed to
give hamburgers a totally random brand
new perspective on their own city and so
we went to see how it works
a key
rack a bellhop
long hallways
and a reception desk
at first it would appear to be the
classic hotel lobby
but it's just a mock-up built in a
project room in hamburg's university
quarter
the lobby is the hub of an art project
titled hotel hamburg the concept lets
participants take a holiday in someone
else's apartment in hamburg in exchange
for letting others stay in theirs it
aims to make art a hands-on experience
i don't have to book an expensive tour
to travel i can travel in my own city
and traveling via the hotel hamburg
costs nothing
but that doesn't mean you can have a
good time at the hotel hamburg for free
you have to open your own apartment to
others from hamburg
most people might not go for that but
there are other apartments available for
sharing like in the neustadt district
home of hamburg's most famous church st
michaels
the historical grocer's apartments or
crying comp
and the hip ganga fetal quarter
this is where the 32 year old graphic
artist lana bragina lives
it's a rare opportunity for her to spend
the night in a strange apartment even if
she has to let a stranger stay in hers
who's her ideal guest
it would be someone like me a girl about
the same age i think that would be the
best
yeah
she's a little nervous about her cat
which will have to stay behind with the
unknown guest
to keep the cat from jumping out the
window she recommends that the new
tenant just tilt it
it costs nothing to check into the hotel
hamburg except maybe some trust
there's no insurance only the most basic
information
how do you get to the apartment from the
front entrance
it's on the fourth floor my name is on
the doorbell
the only security deposit the
participants have to provide is their
name and address
and they're ready to start their holiday
the hotel hamburg even has bellhops to
bring the guests to their rooms
as it happens lana bregina's suite for
tonight is only a 10 minute drive from
her own apartment in this historic
high-rise
but finding the right apartment among so
many is not that easy
it's pretty dark in here
and rather small
the view from the eighth floor is some
compensation to lana it's like a voyage
of discovery with a touch of mystery
since she knows nothing about the tenant
everything here tells a story they refer
to a certain individual
it's very interesting because i don't
know her but she's still allowed me in
here
that's part of the game
the rules of the game apply the other
way around as well
the unknown guest in lana bregina's flat
is a 24 year old student marie therese
yesa
poking around unobserved in a stranger's
apartment is part of the attraction for
her too
i know people take a peek at others
bookcases now and then but snooping into
every nook and cranny is something you
wouldn't usually do
it's interesting to find out who this is
so i think it's really a good thing
not only can they explore a stranger's
apartment but a strange neighborhood as
well
lana has even run into some friends
she's not completely unfamiliar with the
area but she's discovering new parts of
it
i've really never been here before it's
so nice to see hamburg from a new
perspective
i'd like to trade my apartment for a
stay in a house someday
lana brought along her camera too just
like on a real holiday
she's seen lots of new signs thanks to
the hotel hamburg
and she's already looking forward to her
next trip through her hometown
well one of the things that foreigners
love about europe is the abundance of
quaint little villages places that make
you feel like you've gone back in time
and while they might be a lot of fun to
visit it's quite another thing to live
in such a forgotten out of the way place
well in italy scores the villages were
actually threatened with dying out until
people came up with some clever schemes
to capitalize on the quaintness
in 1987 monte gridolfo was all but
deserted
this is the mountain village today
regional government and italian fashion
designer alberta ferretti spent some 13
million euros to turn a medieval palace
into a four-star hotel
the investment has helped save the
village from becoming a ghost town
restoration projects like this are very
costly because you have to respect and
preserve the village's history
fortunately most of the tourists who
come here are not looking for tourist
attractions and only a minority want a
package tour kind of thing
the grotto is now a restaurant
the former orangery is the breakfast
room
and the court garden now has a pool
modern amenities set in medieval
ambiance are especially attractive to
foreign visitors
everything is so fast and you have to
work hard and have all these hobbies and
friends and do everything in short time
so
and here is like
no time you can just do
everything very
peaceful or on your own beast like
so i think that's why
to just get out of the everyday um fuss
the quaint town of verucio is another
place for a holiday in medieval
surroundings
here centuries-old houses have been
remodeled as lodgings and restaurants
guests can take an active part in
village life
the idea came from an initiative called
albergo de fuso or scattered hostels
founded in 1982
83 similar projects have been launched
around italy
another example is the case antique
antique houses a night here costs 350
euros
we weren't allowed to alter the house's
appearance or install any new doors or
windows
those were conservation order
requirements
and that made the work on this village
and this house
rather complicated
the value of the house reflects our
investment because it costs quite a lot
to restore something like this
the medieval holiday model is often
worth the investment
in 2007 the italian village castelfalfi
lay in ruins only five people lived in
the small town just west of florence
german travel company tui bought the 11
square kilometers around the village and
invested some 250 million euros
a second hotel is just open for business
here only the facade is medieval the
interior is entirely modern
most investors buy up the village and
strip away its identity they don't care
about the villages like albert
they just turn them into tourist
villages
foreign investors think in these
categories as well
they don't care about the village like
one of the residents would
but it doesn't have to be that way
25 people now live in the village of
monte gridolfo
most local residents found work at the
hotel
these are jobs that help ensure the
future of their community
these jobs are really important to us
the more visitors come and the better
they feel the more tourism we'll have
and the more jobs for local people
everything is changing there was nothing
here before it was just a small town and
deserted now we've got life here again
so it's a very fundamental change
a vacation in the middle ages can be
just an investment
or with a little more respect it can
also be a dream come true for both
locals and tourists
well german basketball player duke
novitskiy is a superstar in the u.s but
when he comes home to germany he does
tend to slip back into his role of boy
next door in his hometown of woltzburg
which is why it's so interesting that a
new documentary will reveal something
more about his personal life the perfect
shot tells the story of his fabulous
career with the dallas mavericks and we
got a sneak preview before it hits the
theaters in september
scenes from the life of one of
basketball's greats
dirk nowitzki has been playing for
america's national basketball
association since 1998.
the man with the perfect shot is feared
by his opponents and worth millions of
dollars to his team the dallas mavericks
a german camera crew followed his life
for two years getting up close and
personal with the game and the player
the end result previewed for the media
on thursday in frankfort nowitzki
himself hasn't seen it he says he has
complete confidence in the director even
if it took him some time to warm up to
the idea
mine under asthma my first reaction was
are you kidding me
i'm actually a pretty private person
i don't have to have everything
displayed in public
and then the second thing i said was my
life is so boring
i just play a little basketball
but the prize-winning documentary maker
sebastian denhart won him over he had
already made films on the boxer brothers
vitali and vladimir klitschko
we wanted to reduce it to a minimum
so we didn't have five six seven people
standing around in the shot
that's what we did
we wanted to make it look like the
camera wasn't there and i think we did
it
dirk novitskiy's discoverer and mentor
holger schwintner plays a leading role
in the film and in the star's life his
unorthodox methods have helped make
novitskiy a world-class player from
vancouver it's crazy the ideas he has
when we started out i was 15 or 16. i
couldn't really figure out what he
wanted from me
among the film's strong points are the
friends and family who add their own
perspectives dirk nowitzki's wife
jessica
they sort of have this
relationship where they understand each
other without even talking to each other
there's many times when i've asked dirk
what is you know
for example when is holger arriving or
when is hogger leaving and he has no
idea
and uh
i don't know maybe they have their own
language
himself initiated the documentary
without even discussing it with nowitzki
in advance
when i was playing basketball nobody
cared you could send a postcard from
italy and it would arrive nine months
later now you get the latest information
in one second
i think film is an appropriate medium to
document his career and i hope it'll be
interesting in 10 years he'll have
something to show his kids
it's a film about the fascination of
basketball and a teenager who left
germany for the united states to play
with the world's best
the film brings together superstars of
basketball old school mates and many
others to define the dirk nowitzki
phenomenon
what i liked most was that it's a really
authentic portrait of dirk
they only had a few days of shooting it
wasn't like they followed us around for
two years but they really captured the
spirit of him as a person
now novitskiy intends to watch the film
for the first time with his fans at the
world premiere on september 16th in
cologne
and with that it is time for us to sign
off so until we meet again all the best
from us here in summertime berlin and
bye-bye
you